あちゅい
どうも、イニエスタです
はい、という訳で
たぶん天気的には外に出ているのが
間違いなレベルの暑さなんですけど
こんな暑い日にヒヤッとする
ドッキリをしてみようと思います
結局なんか暑いときって
聞かれたら終わりだな
あのこんな暑い中に僕の家に来る人たちに
素晴らしいドッキリをしてあげようと思います
夏といえばこちら
まあ実際どれぐらいの効果があるかが
よく分かんないんですけども
涼しいことには間違いないんすよね
(ｼｭｯ ｼｭｯ ｼｭｯｰ  ｼｭｰｰｰ)
おーーー
(ｼｭｰｰｰ)
ｱｯ! ｱｯ! ｱｯ! ｱｯ!
ｱｯｰ! ｱｯｰ!
局所的な打ち方はよくないです
えっめっちゃ冷たいやんこれ
それっぽい冷却スプレーをたくさん買ってきました
まぁ色々あるんですけどなんか1個ですね
これ-85℃までいくやつがありまして
-85℃ってさぁ
あぶなっこれ大丈夫？ほんとに
(ﾋｭｯｰ)
わっ　もう
(ｼｭｯ  ｼｭｰｰｰ)
ﾊｯ! ﾊｯﾊｯ
(ｼｭｳｰｰｰｰ)
やば、やばい！
よかったでもなんか、-85℃と言いつつ
たぶん一瞬だけ-85℃だろうね
(ｼｭｰｰｰｰｰｰ)
えっ待って、凍っちゃったじゃん服
待ってw ねぇー凍っちゃった凍っちゃった
すげーな
ﾌｯﾊｯﾊｯﾊｯﾊｯ
う"ぉい
すげーなー
というわけで今日のドッキリは
をやってみようと思います
うちのドアの扉が鉄なんで
鉄って温度を保ちやすいんですよ
熱いもので熱すればずっと温かくなるし
冷たいものをかければずっと冷たくなるんで
まぁ今回のこのドッキリは完全に適正だと思いました
やばい、もうすぐターゲットが来ます
早速仕掛けていきましょう
ビューン
かけます
(ｼｭｳｰｰｰｰｰ)
(ｼｭｰｰｰｰｰ)
(ｼｭｩｰｰｰｰｰ)
(ﾋｭｰｰ ﾋｭｰｰｰｰ)
暑い
外が暑くてなかなか凍らないです
(ｼｭｳｰｰｰｰｰ)
(ｶﾞﾁｬ)
(ｶﾞﾀﾝ)
(ﾋﾟｰﾝﾎﾟｰﾝ)
(ｶﾞﾁｬﾝ)
(ｶﾞﾁｬ)
たなっち）え？
た）なに？
(ﾋﾟﾄ)
一応ドアノブを-85℃にしておきました
だめだもう…
地球が暑すぎて冷めちゃった
た）だって冷たいですよね
冷たい
た）ただ冷たいだけですよね
そう
80…-85℃にしたんだよこうやって
(ｼｭｰ ｼｭｰｰｰｰｰ)
ほら
これ…待って
た）ねぇー
待って、ねえやばいまじでやばい
た）銀色になっちゃう
(ｼｭｳｰｰｰｰｰ)
(ｼｭｰｰｰ)
(ﾋｭｳｰｰｰ)
(ﾋﾟｰﾝﾎﾟｰﾝ)
ようへい君ちょっと出てもらっていいですか？
ようへい君）はい
すみませーん
あーすいませんお願いします
よ）ねぇー
ほら早く早く、もうすぐすぐ
よ）ねぇもう絶対なんか…
よ）なにっ！？
よ）ｱｯｰ!! ｱｯｰ!!
よ）えっびっくりした！
早く早く…
よ）ﾊｯﾊｯ… いけないの？
[ED ～サンバ風の音楽を添えて～]
よ）うお冷たっ！
ﾊｯﾊｯﾊｯﾊ
ﾊﾊﾊｯ
ｱｯﾊﾊﾊｯ
よ）これなに塗ってんの
ﾊﾊﾊﾊｯ
よ）冷たいんだよなー
よ）あれっすか？
よ）ｼｭｰｰのやつ？
いや、なんか-85℃です
よ）えーー
た）さっきより全然冷たい
た）あっ！これガチでやばい
ガチでやばいこれ
みなさん危ないので-85℃はマネしないように
はい
うわっ氷取れてんじゃん
うわっやばっ
ｱｯﾊｯﾊｯﾊｯﾊ